[Music]
we're going to go back to
william grider again he wrote a book
called the secrets of the temple
which is about the federal reserve a
book he wrote previous to that was about
david stockman
and most recently grider authored
who will tell the people which is quite
popular nowadays
now along with the federal reserve
section of the program
we're going to talk about the secrets of
the federal reserve this is a book by
eustis millen mullins
his book dovetails nicely with that of
william grider
now greider used to be the
managing editor of the washington post
so he has some good establishment
credentials
and also consequently gets reviewed by
the establishment press jack i guess
maybe we should
talk briefly about the stockman book
and see how that glides into the federal
reserve
well the stockman book turn began as a
as a newspaper or a magazine article
back in the early 80s as the uh
reagan revolution was taking over and in
which led of course to the horrendous
deficits that we've got now
and uh grider interviewed stockman at
great length
and got from from stockman the admission
that they didn't know what the hell they
were doing
and they were just conning people and
they were acting so confident
john kindly confident style even though
they didn't know what they were doing
that everybody thought they knew what
they were doing and they didn't
and stockman was was very quick to say
that
that the budget was out of control that
their numbers didn't track
that they didn't know really what
everything was going to lead to
and what it did lead to of course was
the frenzy of feeding
in congress when when the reagan
administration proposed the tax cuts
in which uh the congressman
democratic and republican alike sold out
to every special interest and
in effect gave away all all the tax
requirements and
which led to this tremendous uh process
of deficit accumulation that we've got
right now
well this one i guess perhaps what
happens when a bunch of ideologues
get in control like that and they're
able to
try to put that into the real world
that's right ideologue means that these
were religious
nuts that thought that free market uh
activities and supply-side
theory would solve all problems
regardless of whether they'd ever been
tried before whether it made any sense
before
it simply was in these people's best
interests one way or the other
to force it through and it was a huge
horrible expensive uh experiment
that was run and failed and and now
we're having to face the prospect of
what we do about it
in that book did they talk about them
wanting to
do all this deregulation and
tax reform etc in order to soak up
so much of the wealth and income from
the middle class and lower class
and take it back to the wealthy or was
this just a consequence that they didn't
pursue
oh no the theory was we it was the
trickle down
or the trick alone theory in which uh
hey let's let's give the rich more money
they will invest more
and make jobs for the poor undeserving
people
that was the theory and it was a
straightforward arrangement and
they began to shovel money out to the
rich and the wealthy
and the established in the corporation
as fast as they could and it was on the
basis
that that was the supply side theory if
you cut these people's taxes
they will create more than enough wealth
and income
to make up for the tax cut which was
nonsense
everybody said it was nonsense and
nobody really believed it except the
poor fools out there that were voting
for reagan
[Music]
yeah that is amazing how the very people
who were getting screwed by reagan and
the system and stockmen are the boys are
the ones to be the first to
wave the flag and vote republican
particularly labor people
there were a lot of labor people that
voted for these crazy people and
supported these crazy people and
re-voted for them in 84
and yet they were they were doing the
country in
and it's interesting then to move on
beyond
uh the book the education of david
stockman
in which stockman admits that it's all
smoke
and mirrors and it's all a game
for juveniles who were running a country
at the time
and uh who admits that they didn't know
what they were doing
and it was a big riverboat gamble that's
what what some people call it
they moved from there of course into the
into the prospect
beyond 81 and 82 of running the country
in the secrets of the temple which we're
going to talk about
a little later the fed was horrified
the members of the federal reserve who
saw this take place
and who were responsible for the
monetary side of the equation
they were they knew that none of this
was going to work they knew none of this
could could do anything other than cause
the problems that they did
they didn't say anything about it
because it wasn't their thing
you got to understand that there are two
kinds of
of economic policies in this country one
is
is fiscal policy which is run by the
federal government itself out of the
treasury department
and that is the the government's the the
federal government's budget
of spending and taxing that's fiscal
policy
the other policy which is far more
important is
is conducted by and is a responsibility
of the federal reserve system
and of course if those two policies
conflict
we'll have horrible circumstances and
that's exactly what happened in the
early days of the
of the reagan administration fiscal
policy was out of control
and and the fed thought it was its
responsibility to not only
halt inflation in its tracks but also
to make up the bad effects of bad fiscal
policy
but there is no coordination of the two
the fed supposedly is independent
and supposedly monetary policy is
to be conducted totally independently of
the government and of the treasury
department
and generally that's what happens
well now didn't uh weren't the
reaganites in a position to put some of
their people
in control of the fed one in bulker do
what need one of these and they go right
along with
this type of policy no even though he
came in under carter wasn't he uh
the answer is no a volcker was horrified
at all this this
what he thought was irresponsible fiscal
uh
action would lead to more inflation
i mean his life's goal was to halt
inflation
and deficits helped create more
inflation
and so he felt his responsibility was to
be even tougher
and be even more more stringent in terms
of monetary control to try to offset
the bad effects of that fiscal policy
and of course
there came a time and and those times
varied
uh when the reaganites didn't like
volcker and as a matter of fact
uh if things got bad enough so that they
refused to reappoint him
and he didn't like him meanwhile yes as
the
people went off of the federal reserve
system board of directors board of board
of governors
the reaganites replaced them but they
didn't necessarily replace them with
people that were
a whole lot different well let's take a
look at the federal reserve
because there is so much ignorance about
it
uh so much secrecy involved in it
uh and yet people want to know what it
is how it works
and who runs it well let's start off by
looking at this book
in this title all right secrets of the
temple
and so what grinder proposes to do is
expose
the secrets of the way the fed is run
who runs it and why
and what the bad effects are and the
temple
run out of the temple the temple is
thought of as the federal reserve system
mausoleum on constitution avenue in
washington if you've ever been in that
building
you will be impressed it's all marble
and of course it was built because the
federal reserve
has a bottomless
pocketbook the federal reserve has all
the money it knows how to spend
is not responsible for anybody to tell
how that money is spent
and can blow that money any way they
want to and they do
it can create money well it creates the
money but the money it spends
is tax money it's tax money it's not
created money those are so those are
separate
the federal reserve can't just print
money and spend it it doesn't do that
what it does is expand the money supply
let the banks print the money
and then it by the process of creating
the money supply
it it gets government bonds which it
gets the interest on and that's what it
spends
for its own expenses well that's its own
expenses but it can interject uh
more uh money into the system
yes well i was speaking of the of the
great marvel mausoleum that was spent
by its own internal money but once again
that's the temple
and the whole federal reserve system is
unaccountable
is undemocratic is conducted
perniciously and incompetently and has
been
against the best interests of this
country almost since its creation
and yet it is never called to account
for its bad
practices and policies well let's talk
about its creation
and particularly in the book secrets of
the federal reserve
it talks about how the how the
fed came about but from a rather
circuitous way
well that's true the whole notion of the
word federal reserve system
every other country in the world has a
central bank and the purpose of a
central bank
is to conduct uh monetary policy and
that's what the federal reserve does
but in 1914 the bankers would not let
the public have any say
and do not let the public have any say
in in the monetary policy of the country
and therefore they created this weird
monster called the federal reserve
system
made up of 12 regional banks
each of which set its own policy and
that was kind of the way they did it in
the early days
later the policy accreted partially to
washington so that was shared by
washington and by these 12 central banks
these 12 regional banks
now in the is in the history of it
according to mullins they there was
a national monetary commission set up
to try to come up with some new type of
central banking system or some system
that would
take the ability of the big banks
particularly jp morgan at all
to play their games and cause
[Music]
panics and deflations and
which were hurting the the general
populace
and the commission didn't do anything
until after there was a secret meeting
of the
nation's uh largest bankers plus uh
senator
uh aldridge who was connected with the
rockefeller family
and and who was on very very influential
in that that com
that national monetary commission and
they got together and
tremendous secretly secrecy off jekyll
island in
georgia and came up with a system of
which evolved into the federal reserve
now there were some they didn't get this
passed the way they wanted to the
aldrich bill put this
tried to get this passed
it was not passed but then later after
woodrow wilson came in
they came up with another bill which was
quite a bit like it
and much to the uh although the
well the banks and uh in other parts of
the country in the south and west were
against it because they didn't want
control from wall street
but it was the same group basically it
was on jekyll island
who behind the scenes helped to develop
the
fed as it became and as paul warburg who
was the
uh principal person in on the jekyll
island
uh scheme uh he
helped to put this together and said
well it isn't all that we wanted but
we'll be able to
to take care of these with
administrative actions
and it was then the bankers who
in fact took over the fed and who
took over as the main stockholders in
the fed
so they really got what they wanted and
they've had it that way ever since
well in 1904 there was a it was a panic
and somewhere in 194195 and theodore
roosevelt
went to jp morgan and said can you bail
the country out
yeah well j.p morgan had always done it
before
the wall street correspondent banks had
always done it before but this year they
had a
hard time doing it and so it became
obvious that the country was too big for
these correspondent banks to do that
and so that's why that commission was
formed up but the republicans were still
in control
and refused to make any real changes
until
wilson was elected the democrats were
elected and then of course they
perverted
the original intent of having a central
bank into the abortion that we see now
which is the federal reserve system
but as like in in dc
all the congressmen say the banks never
lose the banks were able to get in and
get control and running for their
benefit
ever since that that's right and what
that does is
point up the temple aspect of this thing
that the federal reserve
is treated like even by the press and by
the public
as some kind of a magic arrangement in a
religious arrangement and maybe like the
catholic church
the chairman is the is the pope and the
various members of the open market
committee are the bishops and the
cardinals
and they go around speaking this latin
language
and doing these strange things all of
which is supposed to be good for us
and pre-ordained and so we shouldn't
question it or pay much attention to it
and that's the way it works
33 percent of the people in a recent
poll
appear to understand that the federal
reserve is the one that controls the
money supply
meaning they're the ones that control
the economy
the other 66 percent i don't know who
who they think does it
but they don't know that the fed does
that and the fed is in
total control of the economy the
government isn't
the president isn't congress isn't the
federal reserve is
and and they do it in a secretive way in
an undemocratic way
in a way that that suits their own
purpose and their own
very narrow clientele which are the rich
people and the bankers and the wall
street people
yeah it's uh
significance for people to realize that
the federal reserve is actually um
a corporation it is owned there's stock
ownership
it matter of fact you said 66 percent
about
people is it's uh interesting that 66
percent of the stock is owned
uh according to used to smoldens in the
in the mid 80s
by uh 10 banks and so
if they're like usual corporations you
can control the corporation real easy by
owning that much
some of these banks are also european
banks but these
banks which own that much of the stock
well i'm talking about the new york fed
which is the main one
they are also interlocked through
interlocking directorates and through
family alliances so it's uh
it's a fairly cohesive group of uh
of financial organizations that we're
talking about there
yes and it's it's a greater argues that
is
that the function of the fed is to uh
instigate depressions to reduce
inflation
to increase unemployment in order to
keep wages down
his position is that that there is no
interest at the fed
never ever in economic growth or
expansion
it's always in terms of is inflation
picking up and do we need to tighten the
money supply and the reason is of course
that
the bond holders who stand to lose by
inflation
are in control of the system and the
wall street people that deal with the
bonds
that's grouder's argument and and i it's
it's a pretty persuasive argument that
that those are the people that are
running the economy of the country
to the expense of the rest of us now
before 1914 we didn't have a central
bank
we had a central bank kind of before
andrew jackson well the
bank of the us now jackson did away with
there was this wonderful quote where he
said that
uh if the people only understood their
rank injustice of our money and banking
system
there would be a revolution before
mourning and that was that's true of
today if
if the people out there who were thrown
out of work and are forced into
bankruptcy
particularly in 1981 when volcker raised
interest rates up to 20 percent
if those people really knew how it was
done who did it
and why it was done and and the overall
result they would probably
probably have assassinated the federal
reserve board
board of governors speaking of volcker
there was another quote
a an economist or a congressman said
putting volcker who was a rockefeller
man brought up
all through these rockefeller
organizations economic organizations
he's the economic kissinger the counter
economic counterpart of kissinger
anyway they said putting volcker in
charge of the fed is like putting
dracula in charge of the blood bank
let's take a look at the fed and how it
works
it some people say it's very simple
all the fed does is determine the amount
of money and the interest rate
but when you get down to it it's a
little bit more complicated than that
what are the questions
of course it's really complicated in in
controlling how much
expansion and controlling how much
deflation you have
and and as a matter of fact the disaster
of the 81
period was a direct result of volcker
either uh either through his own
interest
picking up milton friedman's argument
that that the fed ought to control the
money supply
by by that process
um that that's the way it was it was
done
and of course uh it isn't that simple it
turned out to be very complicated and
a changing target but the fed has a lot
of a lot of functions it has more than
one function
at first it it's supposed to control the
money supply
and second is supposed to uh be a lender
of last resort to its banking members
now all banks are members of the fed
uh a lot of banks are not federal
reserve members most banks are not
federal reserve
system members they're either state
banks are there national banks who
aren't federal reserve
there's some something other than that
so the fed lends money
to banks who can't get money any other
place and so that's another function of
it that was the original function that
was the original intention
of how to change the money supply and
then finally it's a regulator
of its own banks and of bank mergers and
of the banking system so it's it's kind
of the
the federal regulator of the banking
system
although it shares it with the control
of the currency and with with other
other institutions too okay now you said
it regulates the money supply
uh first of all how does it do this well
it buys
its primary method is to buy and sell
securities
federal securities in the open market
and by taking
taking the securities uh off the market
and replacing them with its own credit
and that credit can be used to expand
credit uh bank credit it expands money
supply by
enlarging loans and by extinguishing by
by issuing these bonds
or selling these bonds it takes cash
money or credit bank credit money away
from the banks
and puts it inside the fed where there
can be no credit made on that
and so the banks can't expand as much
make as much
lending expansion when they are holding
bonds as they can when they're holding
federal reserve credit
so when they sell though these are u.s
government bonds they can be any type of
bonds no they're they're government
bonds
so when they sell bonds they're
replacing when the bonds are sold the
the banks or whoever buys the bonds pays
in
in bank cash and the bank cash is taken
out of circulation
so that reduces the money supply okay
and when the opposite takes place
when when the bonds are bought the fed
replaces the bonds
and replaces those bonds in the in the
public's hands
with money that can be used to expand
credit so
then what happens to that that creditor
money the banks
how do the banks the banks the banks
then create money through the banking
process by making loans
because they make bank money and bank
money is deposits
and and so they expand their deposits by
making these loans
when you make a loan what you do is tell
tell whoever you make the loan
okay guys we have just created a credit
in your name in our
in our deposit account so
what they do is just open up a new
deposit
in that bank which acts like money and
you can check on it
so they're really creating money they're
creating money and that's that's the
magic here
the whole notion of creating money
particularly paper money
has a magical air about it it's one
thing to understand that gold
or silver can be money once you mine it
it's worth something it's money
but to create money paper money out of
thin
air and buy things and do things with
with that is magical it has a religious
connotation
that's what greider argues and that's
why it's called the temple because the
the institution that creates the money
in this magical way has got to have
something religious about it
well there's more than that though of
course it goes on to the fact that if
you create too much money if you spend
too much money it's sinful
you you are you are a sinful person or
you are a sinful country
you have overspent your your ability and
you must suffer
the result is that that you must pay the
price
and the fed makes you pay the price and
therefore we've got all these
these calvinistic attitudes about money
and overspending and underspending
and that's why it's called the temple
and that's why the politicians i guess
don't want to be responsible for it and
they are not
only these fed people are responsible
for this and they are
answerable to nobody now why would
they want to increase the money supply
well uh if if the country is
is needs to expand
and to the extent that that there's no
inflation
then that's always the overriding
concern is there inflation is there
danger of inflation
then of course as the as the country
creates wealth through manufacturing and
through production
there's got to be an additional amount
of money to cover that
otherwise there's not enough money to
cover the new additional
wealth and you will have depression and
deflation which is what we had
all during the the last century we had
deflation all during that time because
there was no fed to create money there
was no
increase in the gold supply and that's
way the goal was based in those days
and yet we had this tremendous increase
in production
and there was no money to cover the
increased production so there was
deflation because there was
the the the product was was worth more
in monetary terms then
is that isn't that the problem uh that
people have
with people saying that we should go
back on the gold standard a strict gold
standard
because the gold the money supply cannot
increase when you need it only if you
get more gold or there's more gold will
that behind
that's true what you do is uh
mortgage your ability to grow and to
expand
to the south african and gold mines
because that's the only place gold comes
from is the south african gold mines
and if they decide to shut the gold
mines down
then you can no longer expand your money
supply if you're dependent on gold
so they have to have a flexible system
where they can print more money
whenever they need to well they that's
right well we need to provide more
credit
we know we know how this system works we
shouldn't be dependent on some
crazy international commodity which is
gold and silver
to allow us to do what we want to do
with our economic system
we can handle that in a different way
and we don't have to depend on
minors or are opening up new mines or or
whatever to do that
now if the fed increases the money
supply
that only goes to the banks that are
part of the
federal reserve system no it gets it
gets to all of them i mean just
through circulation yeah because uh
let's assume first that that only
federal reserve members buy uh or get to
get the bank credit which isn't true
anybody with bonds
can sell those bonds to the fed and get
bank credit treasury bondsmen treasury
bonds right and so if the fed is in the
open market to sell bonds
anybody can do that okay and and that
includes insurance companies individuals
anybody but only the commercial banks
have the ability to expand the money
by making bank money so that's where the
expansion takes place
so any bank that gets bank credit can
expand the money supply whether it's a
fed member or not
now can the fed help to in
to create prosperity by creating more
money thereby stimulating the economy or
does it only follow when the production
goes up like you say
theoretically the the fed is supposed to
follow production
and expand the money supply to
accommodate it
but it doesn't always do that and that's
been the problem in fact it's
it's been just the opposite in cases and
it
it has been a failure in a lot of cases
to do what it should have obviously done
which is accommodate production it's
been
it is overly concerned with inflation is
overly concerned with wages being
higher than somebody thinks they ought
to be and so its interest is not to
accommodate production
but to cut off wage increases
and and to increase unemployment in such
a way
that inflation can be kept to a minimum
and that's its goal
now that's not supposed to be its goal
but the people that run this
fed and the banking system that's in
control of it
choose to do that now we've had the full
employment bills
they've been passed they've never been
applied to the fed
and yet the government is in favor of
full employment
but we never have it we'll never have it
as long as the fed
is independent of politics okay let's go
the opposite what happens when the fed
decreases the money supply
we decrease the money supply you cut off
credit
uh you cut off people's ability to
borrow and people's ability to pay
and people's ability to expand so you
have a depression
and that's what we had in 81 because
that's what they did they cut off the
money supply in 81
and we had a depression uh mullins talks
about
the depression of the 20s the early 20s
they were saying there's prosperity
particularly economic prosperity
and small businesses and all but the fed
suddenly
retracted uh all so much money and
credit
uh that the small business and the
farmers could no longer get credit
we had a depression the farmers were
driven off the land a lot of people were
driven out of business
and the meanwhile the big guys who had
the money
were able to come and uh buy up a lot of
land and a lot of uh
smaller companies at bargain basement
prices and his point
says he sees that this happening on a
periodic basis
where they can go in and do that but
this one he
uses it as a prototypical example of how
the fed connect can cause
a depression and particularly then
selectively particularly hurting certain
segments of society and the economy
well he i think he points to the the
depression of 21 because that was the
first time
the fed had a chance to do the right
thing and it did the wrong thing
and it's done the wrong thing almost
every time since then
i mean this federal reserve is not in
our best interest
this federal reserve never works in most
of the public's best interest
and grider makes the argument that
they're really there only to protect the
bondholders
and to minimize inflation minimize wages
whether that's true or not the truth is
these people have blown it too many
times
and you can just go right down the list
of every depression has been caused by
the federal reserve
since 1921. since we've had the federal
reserve
absolutely they have caused it and
they've caused it
as an attempt to try to restrain
inflation restrained growth
sometimes that might have been useful
and of course
in 1979 everybody wanted that to happen
but these people overdid it
and they overdid it because they didn't
think
first they are unaccountable and they
could
they could bankrupt as many people as
they wanted to and laugh in everybody's
face and that's what they did
so they've got no no harm
comes to them to overstate their case
and so they've got no
incentive to not over overstate
everything they do and that's what they
always do
okay we talked about expanding and
contracting of the currency what about
the uh interest rates well
interest rates flow from from the supply
of money
supply and demand for money uh is is the
factor that causes interest rates to
fluctuate because interest rate is a
price of money
and if you expand the money supply then
you expand the amount of money and then
you
drive down the price of money which is
interest but the fed can
crank it up or take it down at will as
as
as it wants to depending on what it
wants to accomplish right
well that's right the discount rate
right generally well the discount rate
is
seldom used the the expanding of
open market activities is the way they
control it and traditionally the fed has
controlled the money supply through
interest rates
by watching what happened to interest
rates as they expanded the money
and if the fed thinks interest rates
ought to be lower
then they will not only expand the money
supply but they will also lower the
discount
rate because
the open market activity in which they
buying selling securities is so
secretive
and so delayed that they have to have
another signal
in order to tell people what they really
mean because nobody knows what they mean
because of the secrecy so the discount
window which originally began is it
is the traditional way that you expand
the money supply and the bank of england
still uses that
that's still their method that's no
longer used to expand the money supply
and to control interest rates anymore
the open market activities is the way
our fed does that
okay can you uh explain that a little
bit further the difference
the open the open market uh
activity and the uh the the weather
discount the window
the discount window's never used this
discount window is a place that a bank
can come
that that uh is is in need of money
in other words it's being drawn it's
it's it's got problems out there and it
needs to draw some money from somewhere
and and originally the fed was was the
lender of last resort to the banks
and the discount window was a place that
came and if you raise the interest rate
you discourage the bank from borrowing
money therefore you didn't expand the
money
but that that didn't work anymore
because the other other things
intervened
and the fed began to use open market
activities
buying and selling securities on the
open market as a way to
to expand and contract money the money
supply but as i understand it the
discount window is used
daily by big banks just to take care of
balance of inbound federal funds
the federal funds market each year the
discount window is seldom ever used the
federal funds market is used on a day
is only used on a daily basis by every
bank
to sell and buy its surplus and it's in
its shortage
daily and it's it's done by wire
and the federal funds rate itself is the
one that really counts but that's not
set by the fed
oh it's not something the fed doesn't
set that the market sets that
but all of it kind of flows from the
fed's open market activity and the
discount window does the fed determine
the
reserve requirements of the big banks
well
they do of their members now some of the
big banks aren't federal reserve members
and therefore the state will set that
reserve requirement the control of the
currency will set that
that reserve requirement but if if they
are national banks as members of the
federal reserve system
then the fed will control them no
there's a there's a split between
national banks and fed members
who are controlled by the the office of
currency that of the
the control of the currency oversees
those people
federal reserve members who are not
national
bank members uh i i don't know what the
current i forget what the current
arrangement is but
uh state banks not in the fed membership
are controlled by the state and then you
have the two federal agencies that
overlap control of the of the national
and the federal reserve
member banks but only federal reserve
members can borrow
from the federal reserve discount window
if it wants to if they want to
mullins talks about how the fed is even
go
far so far as to make loans
independently of the us government
loans to foreign banks or foreign
governments
does grider talk about that at all well
the new york fed
controls are or is the operative
for our international monetary balancing
process
and generally that's done in cooperation
with with the department of the treasury
because the treasury has a very very
strong interest
in external uh monetary affairs
and that's something really that that is
kind of shared
i think i don't know what mullen was
talking about when he said
was he saying that fed made loans right
and
well independently of the us government
in the past it has done that when
it considered it was wise to help out
either
a central bank in europe or or some
uh organization like that rider doesn't
deal with that
and generally that's not done anymore
independent of the treasury the treasury
the state department is very much
involved with that kind of circumstance
and there's a lot of cooperation between
the state department the fed on that
score
one of the things that people criticize
the fed for
is uh that it can make or break a
president
now is this true the fed says no but is
this true and has it done it arthur
burns helped make
nixon and uh and the federal reserve has
never lived down the shame
of him pandering to nixon how did he do
that
well he he expanded the money supply
during the election
and that created right and we didn't
have the kind of situation that bush
faced
by having a depression in the middle of
his campaign and
uh the most graphic example is is that
poor foolish carter
appointing volcker who immediately uh
contracted the money supply in the
middle of that election
and that's what beat carter and bert
lance told him that if he elected
if he appointed volcker that volcker
would do that
and that carter would lose that election
and he did
bird lance was a banker that knew knew
what was going on
but i'm afraid those other uh simple
people from georgia around
carter didn't understand all that
it's i think it's very revealing
that looking at the history of the
federal reserve
since we've had it that the chairman of
the house banking and
currency committee with a couple of
exceptions
have been very opposed to the fed very
critical of it
and would like to see it abolished i
don't think
abolish is the word frank i think i
think brought under political control
and brought in this part of the
government
okay the advocacy is for the federal
reserve to become a branch of the
treasury
and that's where it ought to be and
that's what ought to happen
but it's probably never going to happen
because we're already losing
us citizens have already lost control of
the government is any reason to think
that we're going to gain control of
something like this
it's not going to happen unless we do
something else
how much effect and control over the
economy and our prosperity is the fed
have
oh about 90 that much control of the
money supply
milton friedman has claimed all along
it's 100 well i don't think it's quite
that much monetarist
the monetary school which controls the
fed now
would have you think that nothing
matters but but
the control of money uh the keynesian
of course thought that that the main
thing that that was important was fiscal
policy
and of course the truth is somewhere in
between those
but monetary i said ninety percent that
may be a little high
but monetary policy is really important
particularly in the in the long run
this dovetails with a quote by baron
nathan meyer
de rothschild the of the
rothschild banking family that has
branches all over the world
through family ties as well as
commercial and financial ties
but he said decades and decades ago that
the man that controls britain's money
supply
controls the british empire and
i control the british money supply
well at least to some extent i think he
was under some
some control of the british government
at the time because the central bank
of england has always been uh
subservient
to to whatever administration was in and
and is
is today but that's in contrast to our
fed which is
which claims to be in acts and and uh
effectively uh doesn't let any
any of the popular democratically
elected people have anything to do with
it
now there are banks in their banks
the commercial banks can do things which
say credit unions or savings and loans
when we add savings and loans or other
types of
banks they cannot do it i understand the
commercial
the banks can create money but the
others have to
they can't create credit except
what they have in their vault so to
speak well not only that but
they also have to be working with a bank
a commercial bank because
what they do of course is is uh lend the
money
that goes through the commercial bank
and and the commercial bank has
it's another matter of fractional
banking
in which the bank only has to keep about
eight dollars out of every hundred land
and then the other other ninety two
dollars is
the credit they create is money uh
the other institutions besides
commercial banks can't create the money
that way
because they've got to work through the
commercial banking system to do it
here's a quote from greider in this
regard
he said the federal reserve was not born
in isolation
it was the keystone of a profound
alteration that occurred in the american
culture of self-government
devaluing the potential representative
democracy and imposing limitations on it
as the new perspective held that the
popular will which was so turbulent in
the 19th century
must be restrained in this new age of
multiplying complexity and scale
i guess that's just a rather complex way
of saying uh
the the big guys wanted to control it
because they were afraid of the
of the will of the people that was in
all this permit down below
well i think that's that's a little bit
overstated grouter
i i don't think i'd want to agree that
there was a change when this took place
i agree the banking system always
control itself
uh there was a time there when andrew
jackson put him in a little bit of
disarray but but it wasn't long they
recovered fast
the national banking system was created
in 1963 to finance the civil war and it
did it
and banks were allowed then to print
money bank money which was
became a full-scale currency and the
banks
control the system from 1863 to the time
the fed was created
and then they got control of the fed
immediately they wrote the fed act
to allow them to keep control of it
there hadn't been any change
i think ryder overstates that what does
this fall under the category of class
warfare that we've seen
in operation so blatantly in the reagan
administration that you referred to in
the
stockman book well well grouder points
out two things that i
i would certainly like to bring out one
is that
volcker and the fed in eight in in in
1980 created the circumstances that led
to the snl debacle
i mean they did it the federal reserve
screwed the system up to the point where
the s l's disintegrated
and then from all of that problem of
high interest rates
flowed the snl debical in the 500
billion dollars
and they never got in the blame part
those turkeys never got any of that
blame
the other thing was these guys
consistently invoker says
i want to break the unions volcker said
i am in the business of breaking the
unions to restrict
wages to keep wages down to make sure
that inflation stays low
and that's been the unstated policy of
the fed all along too
to break unions to keep people in the
lowest wage levels they can
and to keep unemployment levels as high
as they can get away with
and they are at historic levels right
now for
the circumstance
[Music]
what can the people do about it given
the fact that our democratic system
itself
is out of control and given that ross
perot was so popular because he was
beaten up
on the democratic system it was working
so poorly
we got to take control of our democratic
system before we can take control of
this monetary system
because we can't go with this monetary
system it's it's too
insulated it's too powerful it's too
secret
and it's just not something we come to
grips with directly without getting our
hands on the democratic system
then to shake this damn federal reserve
system up